today's episode is brought to you by
blue chu and now if you like sex because
most do most most like sex and if you
like sex blue Chu offers men a
performance enhancement for the bedroom
or elsewhere you could do it wherever
you want you know if somebody's willing
to accept that hard-on bra that H oh
then you could serve it wherever but
wouldn't you like to last longer and go
extra rounds at blue Chowk aam you can
get the first chewables with the same
active ingredients as Viagra and Cialis
now chewables can work faster than pills
up to two times as fast that's twice as
fast
the chewables from blue shoe can be
taken on a full stomach or an empty
stomach so if you have a full stomach
you can have them if you have a empty
stomach you could be like oh I'm hungry
but don't have like 50 or 60 because
that's not gonna fill you up it's not a
meal it's an it's an additive really
it's something else you have you can get
an online physician consult that is free
so it's cheaper than those other two
Viagra and Cialis it only takes a few
minutes to connect with a blue-chip
affiliated physician and if you qualify
you can get prescribed online quickly
not shocking you can get everything else
you want in the world
of course you could catch a little bit
of that hard heat you know you can catch
a little bit of that front blood bra
that v hoof you feel me get add there is
no in-person doctor visit no awkward
conversations so it's not like hey what
about this you know wiener it ships
directly to your door in discreet
packaging maybe a guitar case it shows
up and people think you're doing music
and you just doing you know a little bit
more peen time
it's a great deal for you guys right now
you can visit blue chu dot-com and get
your first order free when you use promo
code th EO just pay $5 shipping that's
right at b lu e CH e w calm and use
promo code th e o and now let's get into
the episode i want to go back to work
huh I don't want to go back to work you
know there's something nice when you got
the children outside and they are
outside and you know they're doing stuff
they got they got you know they've been
having a little bit of grill meat in
them they got a little bit of conern a
you know some I'm bored guessing some
queso you know you got it's something
nice when the children are outside
they've been drinking kool-aid or
drinking hose water that's what I used
to love being young that hose boy
remember that do where we live we need
in have a hose so I remember going to
somebody's house and they had that hose
and it was like damn y'all got dis a
damn much water as you want just coming
out of this magic rope oh dude I
remember just putting that thing
straight in in my dome hole one time and
just taking on as much as I could my god
I mean I was so I was just camel DUP
brah
I was just h2 algebra I was filled with
that aqua you know Ana Latinos call it
that agua and we in its water but they
don't know how to say it it's like wow
wow like now Wow tur but that's where we
meet together and we teach each other
you know but I remember that man that
house hos boy just a magic ass rope that
came out from somewhere and it would had
that water in it and in summertime the
water tasted a little bit like the pipes
you get that hidden but I or if you were
the first person to take a sip off the
hose after somebody turned it on that
person was a psychopath maybe I don't
know let's ask everyone yes yes that
person was because that that first hit
had that it was rust it was it tasted
like house had a little bit of paint and
it maybe a little bit of iron
supplements in there that first hit boy
if somebody just went straight off the
hose after somebody turned it on it was
always real hot and that we did I
wouldn't have that but I did my boy
Daniel that lived in our neighborhood he
would that was his big thing and he
ended up getting into drugs and alcohol
and drugs and he um but his big thing
was he liked to get that hot hose hit
that first one that one that you know it
tastes like a damn two years of science
class right up in that first gulp
it'll make you [ __ ] you know it'll make
you bones
pretend like they don't know each other
that [ __ ] has got so many minerals and
stuff in it you know and you have a dam
you get that first hit off the hose that
hot hose hit boy and Daniel would do it
he would do one and he go to the
neighbors and do another next thing you
know he's testing positive for
phosphorus and for you know boron and
[ __ ] next thing you know you know he'll
walk around a room and the the the the
the light bulbs in a room will kind of
turn and follow him like he's all
because that hot house hit had different
elements in it had iron you know had all
kind of stuff sometime there be a you
know some stuck animal in a pipe and
Daniel just take that thing to the dome
boy he just just Huff a weasel off that
first hit of hot house
and he was risky he was always kind of a
risky boy he was always I mean really
always just kind of that risky boy let's
go
[Music]
celebrate ms
you know that soon
have some fun while we all celebrate dog
day
celebrate all y'all
[Music]
Oh
let's have some fun while we all die
little morose out there sorry but that
song is also positive let's all head
let's have some fun let's have some fun
when we're out while we're out here
oh good to see you today even of even
audio even / audio I know you're there
I'm here it is July 7 Sunday evening
here in Los Angeles and it's summer is I
mean it's the dog days of summer yes
even hell right now
even Hades that closed down they said
closed for the summer it's hot says so
hot everywhere you don't need we can't
do any business right now that's why
it's kind of beautiful I think if you if
you die in the summertime you know if
you relinquish your living pass you know
if the Lord gives you two yellow cards
and send you on up in the summertime you
you pretty much go to heaven because
Hades is closed for repairs because
Mother Earth is putting on our own warm
freak show out here called summertime
and it is spicy
I mean it's people do people talking
like that people can't even even
people's ideas are real dry you know if
you get a nod if you if you you know if
you got a couple ideas out of somebody
and you put them on a plate you'd
probably be able to cut them up with a
credit card and then hit them hit put
them cats any African and you little
going and you little to go bring in a
little to-go box and your head your
brain you'd be able to free freebase
them homeboy
because even people's ideas are they're
just things are there's not a lot of
moisture running around you know it's
not even as the summer is really not a
good time for sex it's more of a time
for for spiders and for getting a good
deal on some cocaine because there's not
a lot of moisture out there
oh that earthquake people kept hitting
me are you okay well dude I'm gonna be
okay if I'm sitting here telling you I'm
okay all the time you know what I'm
sorry to get upset man with that amen
just checking somebody sent me all caps
are you okay heard there was an
earthquake we don't now you're alarming
me what am i ha-ah
it just look if there's an earthquake
just assume I'm taking the natural
precautions I did what I should have
done I googled what do you do during an
earthquake okay that's exactly what I
did googled what do you do during an
earthquake and then the first thing I
got it uh it had an advertisement for
like an earthquake helmet [ __ ] I ain't
wearing an earthquake helmet okay
ain't no little shake
a lot of these fools can't handle the
shape ain't no shake huh
I'm not wearing an earthquake helmet I'm
sorry and I'm sorry if I sound real
feisty about it but I'm not doing it
I'm not putting on a helmet if I you
know if I feel like Mother Nature's
acting wild that's not really Who I am
you know I'm more you know I'm not that
guy and I've said it before I'm not
gonna do her a helmet if I'm wear a
bicycle if I have a bicycle
I'm not never letting my son see me in a
bike helmet because a child can't get
that image out of his head of his father
on a dam you know on a six-speed with a
with his basket on the front and a damn
bike helmet on I mean that kids can end
up and probably rehab rehabilitation or
you know we're doing something wild
you know burying him you know doing
something crazy burying himself at the
beach or something you know doing crazy
stuff so you just have to you know you
got to know what you're gonna do and
what you're willing not to do because
it's hot man mother nature's you know we
kind of rely on Mother Nature a lot
don't we you know we rely oh yes she's
gonna come around with that next with
that next card she's gonna play that
summer and then she's gonna play that
that fall to autumn and she gonna play
that winter car and then she'll be back
with the spring look everybody knows
some of these matches out there and some
of these male [ __ ] can be unreliable
so mother nature you don't know if this
bench is fully reliable she's only been
doing the seasons how long do we know I
mean Google that right now how long
uh yeah this doesn't even notice says
Four Seasons get a night at the Four
Seasons see this is a problem with the
world you know I'm trying to learn about
mother nature next thing you know I'm
sleeping somewhere for $700 but we don't
know how long she's been operating so we
don't know when she's gonna give up she
might leave the table for a round and
say you know what I'm sitting this one
out it's autumn only this year it's
summer only so we just don't know so we
gotta just I think you know right now I
got to be grateful that I have I got
water I got I got uh what else I'm doing
Hoover you know so everything is okay
everything's gonna be okay um what else
is going on what else is happening I
ain't been playing video games I got
modern warfare call of duty and it's fun
it's definitely fun but it's different
it's a lot different I felt like than
when I was young
these give the video games now you can't
really lose every time you get a little
they got a checkpoint they call it you
check oh you got the checkpoint whenever
you start back again you start right
here buckaroo good luck good luck young
buck you're gonna be you're gonna do
great out there then when I was young I
remember you had to look if you whedon
it like you had a couple of lives and if
you lost them all guess what you had to
start over at the beginning of the game
and it was insane I remember if you got
to the point where you gonna fight the
bad guy remember you're gonna fight
Bowser dude I would pause the game dude
I would take a break you know I get my I
get my brother doo-doo-doo a massage
doing massage my hands I be putting
chalk on my hands I'll be doing cleaning
jerks in the yard I would get ready if
you were about to fight Bowser I would
get a rest for two days just leave it
leave the screen on I would be there was
no spike grandma she's my good-luck
charm invite her over grandma would
drive down from Illinois if I'm fighting
Bowser you had to prepare this was it
this was the big showdown you weren't
gonna get a million chances at it
remember you would do everything you you
you know you'd have maybe your dad would
even come back and seen you in years he
shows up to help you [ __ ] to help you
just to watch you fight him and he's in
disguise because you don't want your mom
trying to get any of the money he owes
and then he leaves you lose and he's
gone but you know but there's rumors
that it was him it was just a different
time and if you were at the if you were
fighting the champ the Bowser and now
it's like you're at the end they got a
movie in between and make you feel
comfortable you can restart a million
times at the end you can't lose you
can't really lose but it was different
back then you had do remember sometimes
you'd have to put something in the
machine the machine broke after a while
it broken yet to put something there to
hold the game in place or you had to
have your sister sit there and hold the
game remember that hold the game like
I'm not old in the game you'd am holding
the game or you ain't eaten and she
would hold the game
but then she would get nervous or
something she would sneeze and move both
her hands to cover her mouth because she
had manners and she and she and she she
[ __ ] the game up and everybody would
be pissed and you wouldn't forget it
even at Christmas times you wouldn't get
her nothing and you and because you
couldn't forget that
but yeah you had look it took you a day
to get to Bowser and by God you would
train you would eat healthy you would
have all your Brussels spouts just
getting ready pause the game upstairs
you're fighting you're ready different
but yeah I've been playing modern
warfare call of duty a little bit I
don't have a I guess I have a screen
name but I don't know how to put it out
there yet out into the ether but it's
summertime is hot as hot as Hades and
it's Hades is even shut down right now
because it's hot enough out here so it
is a free-for-all in heaven right now
everybody's getting in what else is
happening I watch the fights man it was
crazy do some of the fights it's I mean
it was I think I was thinking about what
do I like about the fights oh and I got
this paid-in-full - if this is a one of
Dustin Poirier shirts and if you want to
snag it us out there on I don't know
what it is he didn't mean no I got this
but but yeah it's out there um I think
Parrish Inc is the company that has them
but um oh and we have an are IP Billy
conforto shirt up as well and shout out
to the embankment gang and everybody
that's been so supportive and we're
gonna do something nice for his mother
with the proceeds she has no idea how
many people care about her son who's
lost who's gone not lost but he's
certainly going to heaven and is
definitely probably one of the toughest
gay male boxers busboy pet owners who
drive a Ford
no Mustang with a convertible top but
the convertible top is inactive the the
sticks of it are there but the the
material part is gone so it's just you
could pull the sticks for but it'll just
looks dumb it looks like kind of two
ants arms kind of but anyway
but you can get those at the Avon calm
slash still work
yes summer it's the dog days of summer
they call it so and I wonder why they
call it that I guess a long time ago
they had you know I don't know I guess
it was so hot that that only dogs
probably were we're still your friend
because people don't want to be a friend
in the summer friendships more of a
autumn time thing summer it's people
trying to survive you know every year a
couple senior citizens they don't make
it through the summer they have
something called heat stroke people just
can't even too much heat form and they
just go go see the Lord they're like oh
it's too hot out here brah catch you
guys on on the B side I'm going to see
the Lord yeah watch the fights Minh the
thing about the fights that gets me is I
think it's just such a thing that I
can't do it's such a it's such a fear of
mine like if you lock me in a cage with
somebody like I'm glad I'm not one of
the referees of the fights of the UFC
because my stomach is just as not built
for it I would stop the fight right when
they got in the ring I bike guys this
I'm gonna call the principal right now
we got to shut this down unless I was
fighting honestly like if they had
comedians you know I I mean I think I
could fight Chris D'Elia probably and
I'd put that on the undercard if B if if
Justin Bieber fought um Tommy Cruz
I go under card and fight uh I'd fight
DeLeon that card I would take to lien
then I think you also put like a Duncan
Trussell up against like a Ben Shapiro
and I think you put like lastly I'd like
to see like a Owen Benjamin verse like a
Chelsea Handler you know yeah those are
some fights that I think would be cool
to see on a card what else man what else
ho there's other stuff uh what's been
going on what's been going on I um I
don't know man this weekend I was kind
of honest like I didn't really do much
for fourth of July I went and walked up
and down the boardwalk in Venice and it
was you know it's nice to see everybody
out there people just enjoying you know
they got a little kid you know sucking
on a beef Frank and it's not sexual
though it's in the spirit of you know of
America and they got somebody they got a
thick broad or someone instagrammed
popping off doing the fireworks you know
when she got a couple mixed kids in the
back of uh in the back of a Toyota
Tercel and there's no you know for one
day it's not about child support or
nothing it's about just celebrating
America it's so it was great to see you
got people you know they had a guy in a
wheelchair and his family had painted he
was in a full-body cast and I don't know
I think he it looked to me like he
should have been in hospital I guess if
somebody's in a full body cast man who
ki guess even at the hospital they can't
do anything but this family had him out
they had him on like a gurney pushing
him around which is weird I you see
people in wheelchairs I never seen a
family just pushing a dude around on a
gurney actually I have one other time at
a party but but yeah not just on the by
the beach and they were pushing this
guy and I just be scared if far that a
woodpecker get into you because that
full-body cast you got a I mean that's a
playground for woodpeckers really when
you think about that I mean that would
be the worst you somebody parks you in
the yard for a minute or outside of the
7-eleven you know and you want you you
you gir need up something happening you
fire or you know probably about a six
story fall I think four stories are
under you probably could be just in a
wheelchair but anything over four you're
gonna end up on a gurney full-body cast
that's what I think I've only fallen off
a think the most I've fallen off a
probably twenty feet and I ended up
actually I got attacked by animals right
when I hit the ground and it's crazy
because if you get attacked by animals
right after you go through a big fall
you almost don't even remember the fall
because you're having to defend yourself
so much but yeah it's summertime and
what are we talking about
yeah woodpeckers that's what I would be
most afraid of if I you know you're it's
you know your buddy is seven eleven he's
supposed to be responsible and he leaves
you outside of the seven eleven and
going there and get a uh you know get a
thing a starburst or something and a
Minute Maid and next thing you know they
got a couple [ __ ] dub peas hit you up
man a couple woodpeckers just start just
teeing off any of [ __ ] in your leg
and arms and [ __ ] you like that you know
you like that you in that full body cast
and next thing you know they got three
or four woodpeckers trying to teach you
a lesson I mean that's really that's the
dark arts right there so if you're in a
wheelchair or something you have to know
who's pushing you around
you can't just let anybody push you
around you got to ask hey let me see
some you know some credentials or
something let me see your driver's
license let me see you know do you know
anybody else that's handicapped can you
rollerskate you got to ask these people
questions because when you put your you
know when you're in a full-body cast and
you let just any [ __ ] lollygagger
kind of just sort just sortal you around
the world you're susceptible to [ __ ] man
dude they park you in a busy spot they
part you know it could be lights out
baby so we got some great calls that
came in it is summertime so let's see if
we can keep you guys cool welcome to
this cool episode we're gonna keep it
cool in here because that was the thing
staying cool how do you stay cool you
know we used to go get water and put it
on the bed at night because my mom the
lowest she would put the air conditioner
I think was maybe 78 so because air
conditioned is expensive and so at night
we would go get water and get a handfuls
of water and put it on the bed and you
wet your bed really with your hands with
with cold water and then laying it and
man it was uh I guess it was I guess it
was awesome you know it'd be so cold and
you go to sleep and you wake up and in a
bed would be kind of dry and you would
be uh and you would be you would able
able to get to sleep but it would get
you over that hump and sometimes you
know it'd be kind of scary to have to go
get the water and bring it to your bed
and you just try to put it out but
you're the hand is not a very good
serving instrument for just straight
water so you'd have to go get a couple
handfuls you running back and forth and
and put it by your keen areas you put a
little up by your head you could rest
your head on the wet sheet put a little
by your heart where you but you know
that [ __ ] mid heater that's the
central that's a central heat unit and
you put a couple down by your feet and
your thighs and you and your organ bro
your low organ your wing and you just
keep that area cool so we got some calls
that came in the hotline is nine eight
five six six four nine five zero three
we had a fella that called in last week
let's play a bit of his call right here
man my ex-wife went through a pretty
nasty divorce in 2017 it was just like
nasty between us we have two little kids
what kind of went on and dated other
people I got my own place now I'm
recently single she's been coming around
a little bit more than she used to
and we've been doing some fun stuff with
the kids but she's been like staying the
night and I don't really know what to do
because she's dating this other guy like
I said kind of feel like it's different
cause we used to be married and they got
kids and stuff and I'm kind of hoping
that we rekindle that used to happen
like you know get my family back to
another book with her dating this other
guy maybe I should cut her off or I
don't know what to do man and some
people called him with suggestions for
this young fella you know when sometimes
we can offer suggestions and that's
helpful and and here is some of those
here's one that came in for the guy here
you go young buck
big fan over here what's up Lucas Lucas
with the lid off that's the old I don't
know what that is actually but um thank
you for calling in Lucas onward 39 years
old about two weeks though you know I'm
feeling that I'm feeling that big-time
oh yeah feeling that age break your nuts
getting along huh do my nuts grew about
probably half fence this year so dude
I'm glad I'm not drinking right now if I
was I cut I cut off about two inches of
my damn nut sack or cinch that thing up
at the bottom and just like a damn thing
a boudin and tighten it up cuz my nuts
are getting he egregious let's hear more
Lucas sorry to interrupt your brother
anyway this is for Austin at a ute I
call down with some recently divorced
some issues you know how to handle how
to proceed during these peak times and
me myself I'm uh you know come August it
would be
one year since I've been separated from
my my wife you know in kids two-step
daughters and a son it's tough man and
she's kind of helped me see look at that
first you want to do the thing that's
real comfortable I know you just want to
you want to slip back into that to where
you were because that's what you're
known for so long if that's what you
that's your comfort zone you know so you
just want to like forget about all that
that pain and just get back in there but
you got to be aware that those kids are
watching you know so you're going to
give them no false hope right so uh [ __ ]
man it's just stuck I feel your boys
pain right there so um you know just
she's all doing her own thing and you
said you already were doing your own
thing awesome so maybe just um try to
keep it you know just friends and don't
keep the kids no false hope cuz they
just take one argument you gotta be
right back to where you are she's
already seeing somebody else like it
easy for her just to say you know
whatever and you know you got to protect
your heart because you're already going
through the pain you don't want to keep
repeating that that issue over and over
again so just uh you know keep your head
up you got some little ones watching try
to get out do your own thing and just be
a good dude
and that's what I'm trying to do else so
hey it ain't easy right and feel listen
a few minutes helped me out tremendously
I thought oh you and Brennan shrub
stupid Brian Collin colander or whatever
well thanks man that's uh that's sweet
of you just say those things any
honestly that's great suggestion I feel
like I mean I don't think anybody
listening could say that that's not a
real clean and you could tell it's right
there with you and your own life and
yeah it's so hard I mean it's you know
it's hard to you know it's hard to
just want to live the reality it's hard
to want to live the reality you know
it's easy to fall back back into those
comfort zones and but those comfort
zones can be the same places where we
you know took each other for granted or
manipulated each other or didn't you
know where we're dishonest and it's just
hard but it's hard not to want them
because they're comfortable you know
it's hard not to just you know want to
be with somebody because even for that
one hour of the day or something you
guys make each other feel great it's
like it's a lot of times that all
overshadow the other time were you
really where you don't or where you
don't come through all the way or where
it's not working but yeah I think if
this has to be a new experience you have
to be a new experience but Lucas those
are great suggestions that you have for
Austin man it's the I appreciate you
calling and sharing that you know in
such a you know such a I mean that's a
really sincere level man you know I
could feel your you know those kids are
watching ya and we don't realize the
repercussions of things that we do
around children I don't have children
but I was a children or child and I was
one child and and uh and yeah those
things they embed into the kids and
sometimes you don't know what they're
gonna be you know what move what action
or something is gonna live inside of a
kid but but I think you just do your
best to mitigate the the number of them
and yeah it's like a lot of times I want
things to change in my life you know I
want this to be different or that to be
different but the truth is life is
always going to be kind of the same in a
lot of ways there's going to be ups it's
going to be downs there's going to be
fairness there's going to be unfairness
and if I want things to be different I
really have to be different you know I
really have to adjust myself I have to
come with a new perspective I have to
take contrary action to get out of the
same right hand circle that I'm always
going in I have to do I have to be
different life for most part is gonna be
it's gonna be life so the variable that
I can control is me if I you know if I
show up to work every day and I hate my
job what if I showed up one day and I
loved my job you know I've had a tough
time sometimes even in my even here at
the podcast and you know sometimes over
the times I get uh you know I would get
you know I get fiery or antsy towards a
Nick the producer and then I realized
well what if I try to just really make
an effort to to be just how can I help
what can I do even if I just include
that with times when I'm uncertain about
what's going on it just and and it's
it's created a better atmosphere you
know it's uh but it's like we just got
it we have to be different you know we
and it's how it sucks you know because
through things I don't want to admit
that I don't want to admit I got to be
different
oh great something else I got to do if I
want my life to change but those are
great suggestions that's kind of a
tangent I went on but that's a that's
such a great suggestion man is that you
know just play it safe stay in the cut
stay where you are
you know enjoy really enjoy the moment
you guys are having I think together
with your children and the rest of it'll
work out because one thing that would be
great to have more than trying to give
the relationship ago again will be the
lifelong relationship of a cup of
comfort and good teamwork that you have
with your ex and you know what be loving
to that dude whoever the dude is she
likes but I do too scarf my dad doo-dah
um you know a set of skating wheels get
him something do something for him get
him a thing of paint or something if
he's gonna paint something oh yeah
there's a [ __ ] thing of paint brah
there's
four gallons a matte finish for you
Randall get what you want be loving
today they loved everything she loved
blow it out the water bra just get a
[ __ ] love Zuka and just start just
play you win every time man but shout
out to both you guys man sound like you
guys are both on the hustle to be some
good dads out there let's take another
call a suggestion that came in for for
Austin Wyatt down there from Space Coast
Florida that's alien country and I'll
tell you right now if aliens come back G
you are on t you they will be in Florida
let's hear more home atom outerspace
hitters just don't tell Eddie Bravo nah
man I had to pause the podcast and call
in about old boy that's heaven he has a
kid with the woman and she's dating
somebody but now she's trying to come
back and his life spinless oh yeah that
menage on trouble that's what you talk
about homework been nice together and
all that kind of stuff they were married
let me just put my two cents I have a
beautiful one-year-old son with a woman
here in Florida we dated were together
for a while we split then tried to work
things back out well i'ma say maybe not
all women but 99.999% of women are out
for attention so she has already showed
that her feelings for him aren't true if
she's already out dating another dude
and then when I try to come to his house
that night and stuff like that so my
advice for him would be keep the
relationship as civil as possible
through the mom and dad thing as much as
possible and I know it's going to hurt
because we all want that family thing I
mean I would die
you know being a picture-perfect family
for my son but it's just not in our
cards so so my advice for him then would
keep it civil be dad be mom but she's
already shown that her feelings for you
are not as real as you would like them
to be with her already dating somebody
else and there you go that's another
outlook on it right there yes if a woman
you know if someone you know I think do
women want attention I feel like we all
want attention I feel like women will
test the water more to see what's going
on men are more reactive and men and
women are more even if they don't know
it sometimes you know emotion they're a
movie they're more emotionally strategic
I think it's built into them as humans
and so yes she may be testing the water
she may be she may just be looking for
attention you never know you know I've
been in a relationship where you you
know sometimes you just want to be there
for somebody sometimes you just want
somebody you know we we all want
different things at different times
maybe she just wants some attention yeah
maybe she does but maybe she's testing
you maybe she's not ready maybe she
doesn't know she's ready right now
maybe her subconscious is testing out
the waters before she puts on her
bathing suit
we don't know sometimes what some of our
behaviors may be coming from a deeper
cauldron then the bowl of soup that
we're showing other people you know
sometimes our I mean what what's going
on inside of us our subconscious who we
are our inner need for things is is a
huge entity and it may be laying the
groundwork for bigger possibilities you
know for for plans that it has that
we're not even able to see yet so
there's a lot of there's a lot in that
but yes you might be looking for
attention I mean I think this gentleman
from down there from alien country
sounds like he mighta you know it there
might not be hope in his situation
Austin may still feel like there's hope
who knows but a couple good ways to look
at it and thank both you guys for your
suggestions for that fella that's kind
of you and it's good to be able to hear
from people who you know I think are
being as earnest as possible with what's
going on with them but it's brave for
any of you guys man get out there and
have an offspring
you know it's wild I just it was just
for me I get scared sometimes you know I
just get scared but I get [ __ ] scared
of everything so if I don't make some
choices soon I'm gonna be I'm gonna be
just 90 year old damn you know just uh
I'll just be in the fray tee up in the
fray tea tree bro because I would just
be a fraidy-cat be a whole bunch of us
out there um let's get into this man
here is what you have to know that this
past weekend is brought to you by
Skillshare Skillshare is an online
learning community for creators yep if
you create something if you like to be
creative nurture that side of yourself
you not realize long ago in my life that
I am NOT a good facilitator I am more of
a creative type I took a test online
that they give to people you know to CIA
people and people in the government and
even cafeteria workers like the main one
not the side people not the scoopers but
the lady in the back with the [ __ ]
you know with that heat helmet on who's
really just rifling all fours baked that
bread get you know hush them puppies
green those beans you know sell us bury
those stocks bro
you know the real hitter that are that
Colonel you know that meet Colonel that
recipe captain
anyway Skillshare is an online learning
community for creators with more than
25,000 classes and design business and
more you'll discover countless ways to
fuel your curiosity creativity and
career take classes in social media
marketing mobile photography creative
writing or even illustration whether
you're looking to discover a new passion
start a side hustle if you want to do
something you want to sell turtles or
something you want to raise them tour
tails bro get one you want to raise a
you know a thing of calamari or whatever
do whatever you want you can learn the
skill on here skill share is there to
keep you learning thriving and reaching
those new goals you could do magic you
could do painting those I think of
something and now you can do it you just
have to learn the skill you want to
learn filmmaking try low-budget
filmmaking tips and tricks for an indie
look it's one of the most popular
courses on the platform join the
millions of students already learning on
Skillshare today with a special offer
just for my listeners get two months of
Skillshare for free that's right
Skillshare is offering this past weekend
listeners two months of unlimited access
to over 25,000 classes for free to sign
up go to Skillshare comm slash Theo von
again go to Skillshare dot-com slash
Theo von to start your two months now
that Skillshare comm slash Theo von oh
let's take another call that came in to
the hotline nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three and here we go gang
amber gang gang amber and that little
mommy huh now wild mommy that undercover
bad girl out there you sound like you
out there shepherdess sheep you know
like you and like you out there maybe
just coming off a yawn you know a late
night work shift for doing some of the
Dark Arts or something let me get
girlfriend go I am thinking about
wondering how you're doing with
cigarettes
I heard you were back on those ready
just wondering if your tapering off and
get him back off the hog well thanks for
checking about that here let's listen to
a little more of you cuz they are no
bueno brother also curious did you ever
try like to jewel and now there's some
baggage around like the kind of people
that might say oh there's definitely
some bake vape there's definitely some
vape baggage look here's the thing
um thank you for caring first of all and
caring about how I'm feeling and what's
going on with me health-wise oh I
haven't had a cigarette today I smoked
half of a cigarette I saved half from
yesterday I smoked the other half last
night and I'm trying to get through the
day no cigarettes now what I know right
now is I'm gonna go to a couple meetings
later there's going to be cigarettes at
the meetings so I have to plan right now
do I plan on smoking a cigarette or not
and right now I say if I'm real honest I
say probably not but maybe so ways I
could prevent that or to Mesa get some
gum get a little sucker candy lemon
candy give me a raspberry candy if I
have a raspberry candy I won't smoke but
if I have a [ __ ] orange candy if I
have a watermelon candy bra I might take
that out and get that Ziggy breath get
that friggin hitter so that's the thing
it's like I really need to maybe look
online for specifically for raspberry
candies and I hate it I hate the smoke
and I hate the way it makes me feel it
makes me feel sick it makes me feel sad
but that's only if I smoked a bunch if I
just have one if I haven't had one in a
few days or weeks or something
I think tastes a saucy boy to think
tastes I mean it gives me a chance to do
something sometimes I just want to smoke
a dang smoke you know sometimes you just
want to [ __ ] piss out of the damn
limousine you feel me sometimes you just
want to just get a spoonful your own
frickin self and just flick it at
somebody so whatever I think I'm I don't
know this new chair we got in here it's
kind of hard and it's kind of pressing
some under her side
but I'm doing okay with it I'm still
fighting it I've done really well and uh
and then something happened I don't know
I jump back in on my jump back on him
but today he's been a good back a good
day in the battle thank you for caring
about that what was the second part of
your question curious did you ever try
like to cool
Alain doing that the jewel or the baby
got nine-year-olds out here they don't
even know that they're smoking oh I'm
doing tangerine bet you smoke okay
okay little Franklin you [ __ ] you
you're a smoker you got you know by the
time by the time these kids are in sixth
grade they're uh they're did I just win
something was that by the time these Dan
is a wizard in these outlets man by the
time I'm in sixth grade they you know
everybody's talking to all the whole
everybody at school I'm you know I was
doing creme brulee it since you can't do
this yeah they don't know if these
things are okay a lot of times you get
to vapes and it made my throat hurt I
did it for about six hours one night and
I probably did about maybe 160
milligrams or something I went through
about six of those little long you know
the carbines or whatever and do it I did
mint I did creme brulee shed I didn't
know what my name was
for one of them but in the morning I
couldn't I think I had part of my throat
it does it all just felt like there was
a hole in it I felt like if I ate him
I've swallowed a marble I would never it
wouldn't even come out mom you know the
other part of my body that's not my
mouth so okay but thank you for a
question let's get a little more from
you I know there's some baggage around
like the kind of people that might faith
but it helped me quit cigarettes for
like three years and then I just stopped
doing it altogether
try it bro so yeah when it come to
vaping that's why I'm at you know
everybody's gonna be on the soccer team
they can't even read or breed they got
you know our butterscotch it just this
[ __ ] seems illegal it just seen way too
while to get kids addicted but then also
maybe I'm getting old and maybe now it's
just better it's just better to smoke
and smoke fun [ __ ] and maybe the same
number of people are smoking as always
because a lot of these news stories who
knows if they're accurate they don't
know none of they weren't accurate
during the election over there during
the last presidential election all their
numbers had they had no real basis on
actual humanity so who knows if any of
these numbers are accurate but it does
seem more either for a kid it seems more
fun if you hit an online or you know Key
Lime Pie or Mississippi mud you got that
Mississippi mud vape pen whereas if you
diss old-fashioned you gotta suck on
that nasty on that [ __ ] sparking just
that Sparky nasty that regular sick but
thank you for calling young lady I
appreciate I just want to let you know a
couple shows this Saturday the 13th of
July we have a new show at the at The
Improv at the Hollywood improv in Los
Angeles so come out to that one it won't
be off
for sale probably until Tuesday morning
but just letting you know that's gonna
happen we also have a show cobs of San
Francisco on July 25th
a late Thursday show has been added that
week upcoming cities as well Sacramento
Las Vegas Memphis Atlanta Louisville
Brea Biloxi and we added us a show on I
believe the 21st or 22nd in Manchester
or in London it's an afternoon show all
those are available at theof on calm
slash tour
t oh you are I want to get to a couple
of patreon questions that came in this
one is from gun squad Gary you arrived
at the studio and it's burning down with
Nick and Gianni still inside you only
have time to save one of them who's it
gonna be
Nick gonna be Nick and that was Nick
there this is from Angela Kohner what
are your thoughts on child actors the
kids on stranger things made me think
about it
I would be proud of my son to be in
something successful I would want him to
have a normal childhood though would you
want the showbiz life for your own child
someday no no I wouldn't from my
experience around some of some child
actors who are now adults it seems like
the odds of them staying well adjusted
are not good there's too many other
heavy influences well money money's a
hard influence to deal with even as you
get older so to have it when you're
young especially in like a me generation
like a me time like where everyone has
is creating their own universes where
the family structure seems to be a
little more confused or a little bit
more evolving I would say no I don't
think it's safe I think you see parents
that are taking these very young
children to do it and it always
seems like there's no way that child
could have made that choice yet if they
want to act or do that I think a safe
fun environment to do it in is just
through school through plays at school
and things of that sort and then when
they get a little bit older you know let
them make their own choice as an adult
if I you know going out to Los Angeles
or New York or even just starting
something in their own area is is is
solid I just there's too much money
there's too much business there's too
much cutthroat type of stuff going on
out here
there's too much dirty influence that I
don't think a child should have you know
kids get in other places elsewhere but
here it can be so much more everything
can happen there can be stuff going on
behind the scenes you don't even really
realize it's so hard to kind of know who
to trust because a lot of the livelihood
here is is entertainment so people are
always going to be angling and always
going to be you know haggling eat just
being alive here in Los Angeles in
Hollywood it's it's entertainment
everything you do is kind of somehow
tied in I mean all your friendships are
a little bit have a little you met them
through work you you know there's always
work as always if it ain't in the house
it's not it's right there you know
peeking in the window so I don't think
it would be a safe environment for uh it
doesn't seem like something fun and it
can be real scary I think a child
growing up with Fame and popularity and
and and like a false sense of self I
mean we all it just seemed very it
doesn't seem wrong but it seems very
unnatural and like the consequences the
ramifications of it could be much more
severe but also you know I didn't have
that experience so I I don't know
exactly it was just my thoughts
diana morton asked why do guys puff up
like lizards when they come around and
meet each other for the first time voice
has changed shoulders get broader kind
of reminds me of bearded dragons LOL
yeah i think that's it that's why you
know if another man come up you want to
show them what you what you got you want
to show them your tits but be cool you
know you want to do the secret
handshakes you know do the whistle
whatever do it you know do whatever's
got to be cool you want to be you know
you want to have that net you want to
seem in the know I think it's very yeah
just tribal goes back to nature that's
one of our natural behaviors that's very
car what does that term cognitive I
don't know oh my neck is killing me bro
I just wish somebody would almost
electrocute me in the damn net let's get
into this question
what's up Co this is a Spencer Bagley
from LA aka Spencer night sweats aka
spencey trips after he pees hey man I
have a question for you I'm curious
what's up Spencer about where you get
your moly cut I'm getting married at the
end of the month and I don't know I'm
having a tough time finding a good
barber here in LA well I'll tell you
where to do it I do it over by Floyd's
over there on Santa Monica Boulevard by
the interstate and my boy John cuts it
and he's a by cyclist but he cuts hair
and he by cycles to get the bad energy
out of his sit you know just to get you
know that that that gumption out of his
system so he doesn't you know do a crime
or fight but you know get in an argument
with his wife he gets all that energy
out about doing bicycling and when he
gets around to doing hair he does it
pretty swell and he and it's pretty good
I don't even like my haircut that good
and even recently I started cutting it
myself again but when I do go to a
fashion shop that is where I go to see
him
what else here we got a call that came
in right here
as always the hotline if you're
struggling with something you have
someone your mind or heart hit the
hotline nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three hey Bo
this is Ginny from Atlanta what's up
Kenny from that ATL the Matlin's boy
let's get it and her I listen to your
podcast most recent podcast about
whether I had look he took my relish
yeah I did or maybe was an epiphany I
was thinking he is relish just okay
pickle you know is it their homoerotic
bad boy it's a good question is relish
that's a gay pickle and you might be
onto something
you know epiphany Kenny out here just
throwing those forethought javelins at
us and they're hitting us you might be
onto something he's relishing a pickle
relish is something it definitely seems
like you know it's almost like a salad
set [ __ ] it let's be jello so there's
definitely something going on there I
think I think it would test positive for
some different types of stuff you know
um so I think there's there's something
in the water right there you got it you
got you got a good uh you got a good
good idea there Epiphany Kenny [ __ ] on
that Kurds bro what is going on man I
gotta tighten up what else is going on
let's take one more call here as always
the hotline nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three you know gay gay
Mike from Austin Texas I often think
about I know you're on the wagon I've
been on the wagon thanks for calling in
Mike from Austin we appreciate you boy
Oh what just fell off a hotel room stuff
who spent a night okay so you dark art
and right now and you out there in the
shadows in thank you for calling him and
I appreciate it bro what's happening bro
I feel too bad don't go too good sad the
sun's coming after 7 a.m.
ooh that Suns coming up yeah man
feeling don't feel too bad don't feel
too good okay yeah I can relate man cuz
I missed sometimes I miss doing that
party I miss letting that dangerous
squirrel just run up into my [ __ ]
brain bruh you and just start looking
for applesauce man sometimes I just
missed that just miss letting that dirty
rabbit just just just climb up in you up
and you a thot cabin and just start
skating bruh sometimes I missed that
let's hear more and I often think how
you handle it if you fall off and if
you're gonna how you will navigate those
waters and guilt or hopefully you'll
never fall off but feeling sad feeling
lonely had a an okay night that's a
strip club got a stripper back to the
hotel had some good conversations no
touchy
which always good okay you got the
stripper you got the hotel you got it
all you got the arts I mean this is a
dark arts it's a dis a museum this is
the the gilligan Haim for the dark arts
yeah I don't know how I will navigate
that you know I mean I think it's like
you know you just fell off the wagon you
said and not feel I definitely feel for
you man like
I mean it sounded like you just kind of
had like a night and and I hope you're
doing okay now it's not like you just
kind of had a party night and I hope
you're doing okay
and that if you choose to you know to do
you know get back on the wagon that
there's there's always a program there
that that's that can be helpful you know
that's the cool thing about it it's like
it's always there it's like one thing
that's reliable for people and you know
if that happens in my life I don't know
if I'll always be so you know be sober I
don't know if I'll always be you know
you know in in that space and in that
headspace
I don't know you know I don't know but I
don't know I don't think I hope you
don't look down upon yourself because
that you know you because you're
dabbling and in in the dark arts man I
hope you get back on the horse if you
feel you want to be back on the horse I
hope you get back on it I hope whatever
you want is what you get
yeah but I don't know man I you know I
think about that sometimes like man if I
would I be able to sustain you know the
activity I have in my life you know and
right now I'm just just kind of taking
it one day at a time but thank you for
calling him and and let's hear a little
bit more and I'm here I got some beer I
got some lines and I'm sad as a
[ __ ] mmm dang gay I hope I don't
know I hope that helped somebody but
there's some good times there don't want
to forget about the good times okay and
gay man I hate he did it I hated thank
you for calling bro thank you for
calling and I mean even kind of just
putting your story out there just as
like
just like III didn't like that you know
and it sounds like you don't really like
it that much I mean it's fun and then
it's not fun that's the thing you know I
didn't like the being there in the
morning and do it I had to cancel what I
was doing there in the day and my heart
just rattle and just like a rattle just
like I just a rattle snake without the
snake boy my heart just a rattle and
like just like somebody just rattled
just something and and I just wanted to
go to sleep and I couldn't go to sleep
and I'm wanting Gatorade and I didn't
have any Gatorade and I was just scared
nice to write a will out I was scared I
was gonna die but I'll just that kind of
[ __ ] I don't miss but but I definitely
miss just letting that donkey just kick
me right in the bottom of my brain
sometimes um but I hope that you're okay
man and that if you don't want this to
become a habit in your life that it
doesn't and that if you want something
different that you take action to to
have something different and thank you
for thinking about me and for even
caring about you know and for caring
about what's going on I love you man and
I hope you feel okay no matter what
you're doing I got to go get a shot or
some bat man I don't know what's going
on but it is locking up I want to thank
everybody for the calls thank you guys
for hitting the hotline and just so much
for the support and whoever you are you
know you out there you know I know we
got a lot of a lot of wildness in our
squad we got people you know Cisco
deliveries them bad boys out there we
got them them them frisky critters
brother that FedEx them FedEx them
overnighters then dudes going all night
with the boxes sneaking through the
woods handing it to their buddy
he runs a leg of it then the hand it to
Carl Lewis he does some then they got
Matthew bowling he runs a leg and next
thing you know that's how they get it
overnight to Portland or to wherever
toss we go that's how they do it you
know you got to know that they got
there's other people out there they got
somebody right now trying soup for the
first time and thinking it's good brah
is it good I don't know dude they got so
they got a baby out there right now for
the first time ever having a little bit
of applesauce that lucky bastard you
know life is happening they got somebody
just found out they're gonna have twins
you know like good things are happening
somebody just won a contest somebody
just want you know somebody's granddad
he just want to what is that thing that
you move stuff but you like you don't
care kind of how you look
wheelbarrow somebody's granddaddy just
won a wheelbarrow in a contest you know
everything's going on somebody just got
a new helmet so a lot of things are
happening bro and ladies so just we got
this just to keep it cool it's
summertime we just got to keep it cool
and and be good yourselves because you
deserve it
I know that
[Music]
celebrate means
celebrate our days see y'all next time
[Music]